So what can we do about it?
How can we deal with these
kind of failures and delays?
We could attempt a network fetch and
if that fails,
get fallback content
from some kind of cash,
perhaps the last content we were
able to get from the network.
However, we have to wait for
the network to fail before
showing fall back content.
And if the connection is slow,
users still get nothing,
that rage inducing life I experience.
This is why the gold
standard is offline first.
Offline first means getting as many
things on the screen as possible,
using stuff already on the user's
device in caches and such.
We might still go to the network,
but we're not going to wait for it.
We'll get stuff from a cache
as much as we can and
then update the page if we finally
get content from the network.
When we get that fresh data from the
network, we can update what the user is
looking at and also save that new
data into the cache for next time.
If we can't get fresh data from the
network, we stick with what we've got.
Maybe it's out of date stale data,
maybe it isn't.
Without the network,
we might not know but one thing's
certain, it's way better than nothing.
Taking an offline first approach
means the user is happy online,
happy offline, and
even happy with wi-fi.
The less the user has to care
about connectivity, the better.
This cause covers exactly
how we achieve that.
But first,
let's see if we can get our U.S.
correspondent Mike Wells on the line.
>> Hey, we've got the connection
problems worked out over here.
I got a whole new set up.
>> Great, so
Mike you're a kind of end of level
boss that these students must defeat in
order to progress on this course right?
>> Defeat?
Well kind of, but
it's not as scary as you make it sound.
I'll be giving you some coding
challenges along the way, so
you can get accustomed to actually
implementing these things.
Taking a demo app from online only
to a fully offline first experience.
In addition to coding challenges,
we'll do some multiple choice quizzes.
In fact, let's do a quiz now.